- Trouver des employés,
un combat de tous les instants.
Dans ce garage de e six mécanic.
Mais quand vient le temps
de recruter, des travailleurs,
la concurrence est féroce.
Surtoui, où les entreprises
minières sont des employeurs
de choix.
MARIKA THIBAULT, coordonnatrice
aux ress. humaines, Thibault GMs
les accoter côté salaire,
puis les avantages sociaux
également. Eux autres c'est fou
comment la compétition est là.
hum., santé et sécurité, Adria
- On a des salaires
concurrentiels, cependant,
c'est très dur compétitioner
avec ces grandes machines.
miniers, plusieurs PME doivent
se tourner vers l'immigration
pour combler les postes vacants.
C'est le cas chez Adria,ents
électriques de haute puissance.
L'entreprise attend avec
impatience l'arrivée de provenae
du Mexique et de la Colombie.
Une démarche complexe
et de longue haleine.
- C'est comme faire un saut
toute l'information et tu es
un peu laissé à toi-même.
J'ai passé aux alentours de près
un réseau de contacts, à trouver
toutes les informations que
j'avais besoin de comprendre
mes démarches de recrutement.
- Au concessionnaire automobile,
on a embauché une firme
pour dénicher trois mécaniciens
aux Philippines. Les deux
premiers sont arrivés en mai
2018, l'
Mais seul l'un d'entre eux
travaill sur place.
- Faire venir trois
travaill
40 000 $. Donc le retour
sur investissement présentement
est zéro profitable.es mécanicié
pour un nouvel employeur
et l'autre pour l'Ontario,
afin d'obtenir sa résidenceente.
- Il avait vu les délais ici
comment c'était ardu et le
au Québec c'est très dur.
Donc lui, il a décidé d'alleres.
- Le seul qui rest
Augusto, qui a débarqué enis
ans. Il aimerait b
sa femme et de ses deux fils.
Mais pour ça, il dr
sa résidence permanente.
maîtriser le français.
- "C'est très difficile"
dit Augusto, qui n'a pas encore
commencé ses cours
dit-il après ses journées
de travail. Il avoue bien
candidement, il pourrait lui
aussi quitter le Québec pour une
sa résidence permanente.
- Depuis près d'un an, le centre
local dement de Rouyn-
Noranda accompagne
de travade travade travade trav.
Ce qui a permis d'en recruter
une cinquantaine.
MARIÈVE MIGNEAULT, DG, Centre
- Les besoins sont là, ils sont
grands, nous, on a été capables
d'en soutenir une partie,
mais il y a encore beaucoup
aux besoins des entreprises.
- Plus de 4300 postes sont
présentement vacants en Abitibi-
Témiscamingue. Alors que le taux
à 3,4 %, deux points sous
la moyenne nationale
La situation est intenable selon
la ville de Rouyn-Noranda et son
Il réclame des changements pour
r le recrutement
de travailleurs étrangers.
mairesse de Rouyn-Noranda
- Alors r
l'immigration économique,
mais en
il va falloir aussi que(&
le gouvernement al
processus parce que là c'est
trop difficile.
d'immigration du gouvernement
fédéral permet auxés
nordiques de sélectionner
elle-même des candidats pourn
leurs besoins en main-d'oeuvre.
CLAUDE THIBAULT, dir., Centre
de développement Rouyn-Noranda
seulement à Timmins, Sudbury,
North Bay, et Thunder Bay,
qui sont tous égalementnières t,
très proches d'ici. La résidence
permanente est assurée
à l'intérieur de six mois, alori
va jusqu'à 36 mois.
- Mais le programme n'est pas
offert au Québec. Puisque ovinci
est en charge de l'immigrati
économique. On souhaite que
certains corps de métier trde, u
soudeur, puissent
d'une voix accélérée pour
la résidence permanente et
que les exigences linguistiques
soient revues à l
Ce que Québec a déjà fait dans
le cadre de programmes pilotes,
pour accueillir des préposés
aux béné
travailleurs dans le secteur
de la transformation alimentaire
et des technologies
de l'inf
- Les postes ont simplement
à être en francisation et non
pas respecter les critères.
es motivations
qui peuvent peut-être
être évaluées.
- Si tout va bien, Adria devrait
es premiers
travailleurs qu'elle a recruté
au Mexique et en Colombie.
L'entreprise leurs versent déjà
une aide financière, pour
qu'ils commencent à apprendre
le français.
- Tous les candidats qu'on
a sélectionnés on le désir,
par chance, de vouloir venir
s'établir. Donc éventuellement
on souhaite qu'ils puissent
avoir accès à une résidence
permanente puis demeurer
pour nous plus longtemps.
- Malgré une première expérience
décevante au concessionnaire
automobile, on a décidé
de poursuivre le recrutement
des travailleurs étrangers.
Cinq mécaniciens marocains
et tunisiens se joindront
à l'équipe d'ici cet été.
Marocains, tunisiens est-ce
que c'est parce qu'ils parlent
déjà français?
- Exact, il n'y a pas de
barrière linguistique, on
là-dessus cette année.
- On souhaite qu'ils
s'établissent dans la région
pour de bon, que l
d'immigration ne le fasse pas
plier bagages pour une autre
province.
Ici Olivier Bacha